okay what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime Opera welcome to another
rant cafe 41 by my count and in this one
we have a doozy everybody we are going
to be ranting discussing and talking
about the phenomenon that is the death
Death Note Netflix 2017 live-action
adaptation it came out six days ago last
Friday it's been all the talk of the
town I'm really looking forward to this
discussion we got anime recon as our
guest we got knucks Taku as a guest and
Salma come back again what is up people
everything's great good let's do this
just finish the Death Note movie ten
minutes ago
I am ready oh okay yeah he thought I saw
this morning on his news video that
we're gonna be ranting about it so I was
like oh no yeah Knox talk we'll actually
watched my videos thank you nukes
thank you 50 something thousand fifty
four thousand watched your you're nuts
video hilarious always you're always
good for a laugh not of your eating yeah
this is gonna be fun guys this is gonna
be fun some positive things I'm welcome
everyone in the chat as well I find this
way because my chat screen is that way
so you know I'm not just crazy but
basically with this whole definite a
death note Netflix thing I watched and
when it came on the same day goes inside
first he's like just watch it you didn't
want to say anything to me and I watched
it and yeah you know let's start with
the good stuff you know the good stuff
is I really enjoyed the 80s inspired
music that's because I like synth wave
that type of music that's like you know
like stranger things 80s inspired type
of music I really enjoyed listening to
it just like for fun
other than that I'm good with the good
things I don't know if anyone else does
anything else really just the music and
that's it
is such a horrid explanation well Mike
no I'm just saying I've talked about the
good things now that was it for me all
right recon maka we have to fill up the
next hour what I enjoyed about this
movie most of all was the character
drinker
specifically for the voice actor we all
know his voice actor the person who
voiced the Green Goblin from spider-man
1
it's just crazy I loved it he was
probably by far my favorite character of
the series unfortunately he didn't
really have that much screen time in the
film I really should get have more
screen time y'all I didn't could've seen
him more yeah yeah that's correct he
didn't really do much compared to he's
laughing in the corner for the whole
movie laughing in the corner like
explaining to light about the Death Note
and old flame trap it's written in the
book well yeah that's right
you know was sitting there with his you
know light-up glasses in the corner
though I he was my favorite of all the
that's okay can we just okay there's so
much there's so much that's even worse
than a heart with the fat lie Luke
apparently loves apples and he heats
like has the Apple and then throws the
rest of it I was gonna say something
about the problem good Apple is left on
that stem that he drops like when you
like that's just evil that right there
that right there was like this movie is
not where were the body Apple there were
no potato chips in the whole movie
I could I could live with that
I could live with no because I'm sure
they got able to ruin that scene but bro
you know chips were the original Death
Note they represent so much evil okay I
hope I hope you know I'm joking right
well um I would have to say for me I
like the movie so I know I'm probably
the only one out of everyone that's
talking about
the moment that actually like to see
like the movie me it was a better light
because he had more justification why he
wanted to seek out justice he added more
like he stuck to his guns better than
Light Yagami did good like you got me
just you know Rufus Lee killing cops and
stuff like that and then it's like wait
one minute
aren't you becoming the thing that you
said you want to get rid of yummy
where's this like he never wanted to
kill no cops in fact he never caught any
cops yeah that was down to someone else
so for me this light was a better light
because he actually stuck to his guns
the only problem I had with this like
really was the ending how suddenly he
became kind of like a genius well as
throughout he wasn't really a genius
there was no sign of him being like
super smart or anything you know it it
didn't take a genius just to look on
some kind of website for the Most Wanted
and then just start picking names off of
it you know so there was no like genius
and element throughout coming from him
until why at the end which just felt
like a complete [ __ ] because you know
there was nothing to back that up Mesa
or Mia
is she is now in this movie just over
Mia because let's not Sully the name of
Mesa about the original Death Note 2 is
that target well is insulting the
original Death Note fair game 2 in
context of the movie well yeah ok
Mesa say whatever you want about me so
the original character she's a good
young that a character and I like I'm
not saying she's a smart character or a
character I would want to be a
relationship with but she's a good
yonder a character in my opinion but
she's not a realistic character in the
slightest
yeah she was terrible Mesa was terrible
there was nothing to it she was really
okay welcome to be
he's all mom let me break down your
logic your logic okay so the new light
is more relatable because his mom was
killed by criminals and he has a motive
but Misa who lost both her parents to
criminals and was almost it will attack
herself she's not a good character
because she doesn't have a motive to be
a fanatical supporter of Kira who saved
her who actually brought justice to the
criminals who got away with the murder
of her parents at attacking her no I'm
not saying that what I'm saying is what
contribution did she bring to the series
what do you mean what contribution did
she bring to the series like what was
her worth in the series what did you
nothing
she know it's not true she represented
uh a barrier like uh a real life kind of
realistic thing that could happen is
that light is this genius right and he's
you know he tries to account for
everything but then you get this person
who is anything but a genius and yet she
also gets this power and now he has to
deal with her he can't just get rid of
her he has to deal with her so it's like
a obstacle a realistic obstacle in real
life in real life you got to deal with
all sorts of people they might stand in
your way you might want to try to turn
him on to your side all that kind of
stuff so I thought that yeah that was if
it was just light working by himself
never having anyone else that he had to
work with accommodate it would have been
less realistic if anything else not
working for himself I felt that in in
the anime itself I didn't like me at all
same thing goes with a movie I don't
like her as a character but the entire
aspect of how I felt about this is when
like told me about the Death Note
the entire thing about the killing why
light what has been killing all these
terrorists and all the stuff was just to
impress her that's how I thought he was
trying to impress her he was trying to
be the good guy just to impress the girl
and trying to get her so the way I
looked at this first of all as far as
Misa and Mia I didn't like Mesa at all I
thought she was a terrible character
although I do see rings you ought to the
series Mia managed to be worse somehow
thank you
however
as far as the movie I don't consider it
to be in the same setting as the anime
light has a totally different
personality and so does Mia and that's
the whole test because the parents were
switched around I doubt lights father's
name was so Ichiro in wherever they were
and Elle's different too
l wasn't an emotional bunt bundle and
wanted he how did he get want to B's
name okay yes good good good point okay
so yeah so many so many issues with this
movie the fact that light who is
supposed to be smart and we were
supposed to get that from the fact that
he's doing other people's papers right
he's writing papers for other people
because he's so smart using it for money
we then see him the first chance he gets
he you know gets this death note this
insane power that you know it as soon if
anyone knew about it they would
immediately arrest him take the death
note maybe do scientific experiments on
and like what the [ __ ] is this how is
this guy able to kill people he's the
first upgrade yes he tells me ahooo he
barely knows about the power right then
and there you're like this guy is an
idiot he's not a genius in any course
wait again that's what I mean he's not
the light he's not like Yaga me he's
like Turner he's all version of Light
Yagami it's like I said in my in my
comment he is trying to pick her up
that's the entire aspect he's telling
her about the power he's trying to
impress her that's what I said well we
saw it would be [ __ ] Lee like what
the biggest mistake I think they made in
the movie as far as introducing light
was that he was doing their tests
because why were they trying to sell
that he was a genius at that yeah I mean
I don't think just in songs like
paperwork means you're a genius I mean
if you're good at math you're good at
math you know that's it
you don't mean you're a genius does you
just got a mess the tail of the light
live-action Death Note was the tail of
light a kid with a boner early on from
when he got punched
he was off the impressing Mia you know
you could see that you could see that it
was dumb that he would straight-up you
know expose the Death Note tour because
it's gonna get you arrested or what you
know that scene when he injured when he
said the Death Note she comes next him
what's that you're holding oh nothing oh
you don't want to tell me no long King
it's some people the child like all
light was more relatable like I just I
don't relate to such stupidity I just I
don't relate to a man I don't know like
it just didn't work for me it maybe it's
because I have an expectation of like
supposed to be you know he's supposed to
be smart but and then you maybe you're
thinking in this movie he's not and yet
then you see at the end actually oh by
the way he just asked for the genius
move at the end so yeah they were trying
to make him a genius but they clearly so
something wasn't driving with the movie
another thing
Jojo talks too much pointed this out is
someone on Facebook told him it's like
Ryu except my name in the Death Note the
only everyone who's trying has only gone
to two letters and there's literally
someone who wrote in the Death Note
beware of Ryoga that was on the back
cover that wasn't on the paper yes on
the corner of the page it was actually
wearing I mean yeah there are certain
things like that do you see anything
wait one minute what's going on and
insane like how are you saying like
about would eaten at the Apple I mean he
should devour the Apple completely you
don't even leave a stem you should just
devour it completely was that the enemy
as well like beware of Rio keys not your
friend was that yes again I don't want
to compare it to the enemy I think of it
all the totally different cast yeah
phenomenon that exists that's the whole
similarity that's the only time between
them
yeah and that's fair but that just I
still think it's a terrible movie even
with that by the way Gigi and the shop
the chat says I feel like they tried to
pander to emos if this movie yeah
definitely it's like oh man life's not
fair I get bullied I'm gonna kill my
bully yeah I know this chick loves me
yeah but then there's consequences no
and that I think there it is definite
death no Netflix 27 people but another
huge blogger Knox
you talked about an earlier you
mentioned how did white know water is
real name so is his name
just water that's it if so why is he
using his real name if he's supposed to
be working with most people don't have
one name I know
and also he when he wrote his name he
wrote a last name also I didn't see it
cuz he was writing quickly and whatever
but he there was a last name there how
he got it yeah but the cult get it why
was what today we saw though he got it
though he was researching it you don't
look up these CIA dudes on the internet
and get their name but that's exactly
what he did he looked him up and then he
wrote his name yeah be able to water
he's supposed to be the right-hand man
of a secret agent whose identity no one
knows the world's greatest detective
just like he exists if you have a CIA
agent who's his identity protecting his
identity is his number one priority the
government goes spends millions to keep
their identities hidden so imagine some
teenager on his laptop being able to
just crack who this guy is his real name
and then use them to control them and
then we have L going into this whole
complete emotional wreck staged him to
going from being an intelligent
calculating
khylin guy to a complete emotional wreck
and also even in the beginning that
scene when L first makes the public
appearance how inferior is that scene to
the anime scene where he figures out
that Kira is in Japan like in Episode
two which is one of the greatest scenes
in anime this so he just comes on it
does like a speech like yeah I'm gonna
find you I'll be honest though I really
love my the one scene in the whole movie
that I liked is when
they propped up lights father to speak
and he saw he didn't get killed
yeah and I hate Mia that is all you have
to kill him
yeah no no but that made sense though
make sense from her perspective but
never be believed he was even fighting
for justice and Nia was just doing it to
have a fun time
she didn't care if they were bad guys or
not it was there was no reason for him
to kill people as there was no justice
dispute like there wasn't the anime yeah
like phantoms wheel pointed out that we
didn't have the kind of you know battle
wits with Ellen White like part of it is
because the movie is shorter sure but it
just didn't come across and also the
whole Mesa
amia decided to kill all the agents just
like that we don't know how many people
these agents were actually investigating
for all we know they could have only
been investigating light and the people
in that immediate area Seattle and if
you do that you are crude clearly saying
basically yes you were on the right
track that's why we killed you
which like in the anime never would have
done he killed all the ages that were
looking for all different Kira suspects
all over the world so they wouldn't know
or all over Japan so they wouldn't know
who which suspect actually got to them
here's a big thing that disappoint me
within the film is that the moment when
Kira was being introduced which is likes
persona in the anime it was a lot more
developed it was slowly pacing a lot
more detail and depth were given by in
the anime and these are in the film
instead it was put into like one minute
of a montage of Kira killing terrorists
and all the stuff and the people praying
for Kira like you missing the best part
this was all happening while they're
having sex yes that's that's a time
constraint in doing it it was ain't got
much time that's alright I think that
was a flaw I mean what are you gonna do
with it I just fell
it wasn't flawless too short in a minute
in a montage for the film but in the
anime it was a much more developed so
that's that thing I didn't really like a
lot yeah I mommy done with us I can live
with but Philly Superman made a good
point in the chat he said that the
Japanese adaptation was also short but
it still did a much better job you know
doing bringing out El and white and I
really enjoyed the Japanese live-action
adaptation it wasn't as good as the
anime because it wasn't as long but they
definitely they were loyal and faithful
to the anime they made some changes but
you could definitely see these were
these characters you can make the
argument that you know the Netflix guys
tried to stay away from the original and
just do a couple of new thing however I
think in itself it fails because
inevitably on the one hand we're
comparing it to the original and on the
other hand even if we didn't compare to
the original
we were just pointing out a whole bunch
of plot holes that don't make sense and
you know someone mentioned the Chad that
Mia seems to be kind of like half Nisa
half light but yeah like sheep soul
oldest all the comments you have about
white not be relatable in the original
and he's not because I believe that he's
a sociopath highly intelligent just
bored with life until he finally gets a
purpose before that he has no purpose
doesn't know what to do with his
intellect but with Mia she is just like
this sociopath in the movie she's
willing to kill anyone she wants power
you know how is that any better well
it's worse not better and not as the
goal soul is arguing that it's more
relatable
look I had a whole discussion with Sol
about light one day last week why he's a
bad character in the discord server and
I do think he's pulled off as a
developed character I just don't think
he's a good character and the premise of
Death Note is light gets an untraceable
unbeatable power
now go trace this guy by default there's
an if they were even close to equally
smart
there's no way L should be able to track
him down it was blunder after blunder
for the first three episodes that sort
of even the scales in Death Note
l was killing a light was killing people
on student hours really he was using his
father's stuff so that they knew that he
had to have information in the police
department yeah but at that point you
can be like yeah he is a high school
student he's not a brilliant you know a
masked criminal mastermind yet right so
you can kind of understand it
well he didn't pose the same tremendous
intellect that slighted and L did sorry
sir honest L was kind of a [ __ ] for the
entire film
I think L was probably the best
character he was big evil genius again
I'm not considering I'm not comparing
him to the original L cuz I think if the
movie is totally different
the only thing that was the same was the
Death Note and that Ryoga did nothing in
both did Ryoga did force light into
killing his first kill yeah yeah light
had zero motivation or drive for
anything in the entire movie and is
legally Luke in the movie he was much
more like evil for the sake of being
evil whereas in the anime he was more
like I'm just bored I want to have fun
kind of thing which you can relate with
more in terms of like oh he's just like
he's this different creature from a
different world and to him humans are
just amusing he's you know he wants to
see what they're all about and that's
his motivation not necessarily good or
bad not black and white just kind of
interesting whereas in the movie we
don't know anything about Luke we don't
know anything about his background about
where he comes from what his powers are
you know Shinigami what are they then we
don't get any explanation he just seems
to be like this evil boogeyman who
screws you over it looks a lot like the
original mr. freeze like due to time
constraints though really because I mean
if you won't eat the explanation of Luke
in there what would you take out then I
would have put a three-minute intro to
the movie
so yeah but what would you have taken
out their sex scenes there we go but but
that's that's the kerosene Stoke so you
take out the care apartment because that
happened during the sex scenes in it
Italy bringing the other thing is it's
implied that nuke just goes from person
to person and gets them to you know
become Kira and that he's done it before
because there was already pages on the
notebook yet no one figured out that
anything was going on before light got
his hands on it
real cause even like oh like you know
you're not the right guy I'll just I'll
just give it to someone else you know
just give it up it's like why would Luke
then give it to him specifically not to
a random person but to him specifically
in the classroom and then be like oh no
I changed my mind I'll give it to
someone else he's trying to test him out
that's what he's doing like if he's
motivated to do this stuff he's trying
to test them all I mean are you to the
Netflix Death Note he released news he's
planning on making a second okay yeah he
wants no bomb means fairway after the
first kill vehicles like oh yeah just
don't want anything anymore
give it a week I'll take it off you know
I think he was just saying that to
pressure light into doing it I don't
know I don't know if it's personal you
never felt like in the first thing man I
know well I don't think he really
particularly he didn't show any interest
in anything he was just giggling the
whole time in the corner yeah and the
other thing is yeah I don't know what
his I don't know what his deal was
because he was like - why he was like oh
if you're not up for this I'll just go
to Mia or whatever but it's like for
what like what do you want what is your
purpose like we didn't get any of that a
shave tie says um he he saw or she saw
like in the she thought I was weird
he thought it weird that in the movie we
have white he's looking at books like
Japanese culture books or whatever
history and he sees like a picture of
Luke as like a thing so it's like people
are supposed to actually know about him
in you know he's supposed to be like a
cult like a mythical figure or something
like that I guess and in Japan
and yet how like how did that not people
realize that this is happening because
people are supposed to once they lose
control the Death Note they're supposed
to lose their memories or do that in the
movie we don't even know but the whole
point is if people know about this
creature
Luke if the Death Note is being used
repeatedly by different users how is
that only when white gets it then now it
becomes a thing where people I go
there's a Death Note before that for who
knows how many hundreds of years
no one ever realized something was off
so everyone else was way smarter than
white Turner clearly yeah pretty much
everyone was smarter than like he was
the dumb character in the movie he
pretty much cold l I'm what I'm Kira and
another thing that I found funny about
the movie you know how he picked his
name Kira into anything you do realize
that him picking his name also sort of
defeats the purpose of the movie the
idea was that they idolized him and that
pushed him further
that's one too he has such loyal
worshipers that the guys like don't move
that guy's light and he just you know
that butcher guy waxed cell with a brick
yeah not even a second thought
Lord Kira right yeah so funnies like he
just assumes it's true like yeah this
guy is Kira did you know bambam Kira if
you translate Kira to Japanese it means
glittering and shining okay so I get how
that means light correct no says it will
tell you the translation if you take a
dictionary and look up Kira it'll say
glittering well the way they explained
the movie from what I remember he said
that in Russian or something
Kira means white which I don't even
think it does but in Japan Kira is how
they colloquially say killer so that's
why actually say that's a
transliteration that's not that's not
you know Japan Japanese if they can't
pronounce ELLs so they say kita and they
can't put consonants at the end of a
word that's why it's kita
that's how they pronounce killer no I
know but like and I agree with if what
you're saying is trouble the translation
that would make more sense but no they
try to expand like oh we'll throw people
off and make them think I'm Japanese
because I'm using a Japanese cloak
realism for killer but it's not even a
Japanese word for killer Japanese for
glittering and glittering is from Boca
near academia there's that belly button
guy you know he's real right you're
right knocks that in the original it is
the people who start noticing so it's
people who online and stuff start
noticing things that criminals are
getting killed and they're like who is
this and then they give him like online
the name Keita as like uh so he they
it's like but he emerges through popular
belief and then he just kind of carries
on that mantle that people on their own
organically came up with in this movie
he tries to like dictate this and like
I'm gonna be known as Kira but it
doesn't make any sense why I'm Kira I'm
making a website don't worry they won't
track that no I know cuz he's such a
great hacker right what his laptop and
yeah and where laptop right he met a
website and then all the people gave him
suggestions on who to kill and one of
them lion he's like yeah do it
that's what he said that's what like
said like said no we can't trust this
what if it was someone who just slept
with next guys like girlfriend and yeah
then she says no but I want you to kill
him and he's like I don't want to and
she's like well had no sex for you know
that's what she she was like what if
some other guy slept with me and he said
I'll kill them killed him yeah like
again like you guys want to compare to
the original I get it but it's a
complete opposite of the original white
who was completely emotionally
unattached to any individual only set
you know trying to achieve his goal
everyone was expendable including his
own family so it's completely different
and also yeah it was Mia so she's
supposed to be smart right she supposed
be the smart one might not necessarily
smart
she's the psychos pushing each port yeah
she's the one manipulating stuff late
but she's the one that's like hey we
should just kill people off a website
where people propose and lights like you
know they could just make that up
because they don't like the people right
well it didn't stump her she just didn't
care yeah yeah but he never he never
ended up taking lightnings off that list
and started killing T he stuck to his
guns which I liked now he never killed
the cops he as far as he is concerned he
only killed people that deserve to die
though on the most-wanted list
that's it except pretory she yeah you
never meant to kill wat'ry remember he
said if he took out the page and ran it
then what we would live and that's what
he was aiming to do and when he got to
the the death note the page was missing
it was torn out yeah yes Joe Joe talks
too much I'm not sure what you referring
to men if you can repeat what exactly
we're talking about there yeah that
whole thing with the burning the page
that was complete like complete a spool
too because it's like oh yeah if you
burn the page with a name it won't he
won't die but it's only one name and no
one's done it before him I mean there
are thousands of names in that book Oh a
soul in a page you can only burn one
name in a page right works I thought
just one name for the whole entire book
I thought it was the whole book yeah
just one name per page I think it's one
name can be destroyed pretty whole book
all right and no one tried to do this
before I don't know but they never had
enough time to cover that did they yeah
I did like the ending I thought the
ending was pretty good well I liked I
liked what I liked it the ending was the
actual very end yeah the last like 10
seconds of them yeah yeah yeah yeah
where you don't know exactly what
happens
I figured that he did do it and that's
it well I would have thought so too but
first of all we know that L says I don't
kill anyone whatever and maybe he had
enough integrity to not kill him and
second of all he's finding and making a
sequel well maybe work with not
characters and L is becoming the
antagonist
yeah well L would probably become a
better hero than right yeah except you
what I tell anyone I talk about the
ending that I thought the ending of the
Death Note live-action was pretty
disturbed D satisfying compared to the
anime well really yes wasn't good at all
it was almost like a cliffhanger why is
that bad because we saw at the very end
L - taken out of page of the death note
from a calculus book and then he was
about to write lights name so he can
kill him but it just didn't happen and
we you came and he says Rioch what are
you doing and his father's didn't even
wonder who he was talking to and did no
one find that strange he's talking to a
quitter thing is he'll end up killing
light in that scenario that would have
been a go-to ending it's like yes he
finally got his revenge but no it just
left off like that boom that is
automatically mean light died I think
that he would have been worse no I think
they did a really great job with the
ending
it was a cliffhanger - no way evil way
anyway like Scrooge giveaway anyway yeah
what they wanted they wanted it to be a
cliffhanger because as as we mentioned
the creator wants to have a sequel so he
wants people look like oh man what
happens next we need that sequel because
that's what he wants he's nude evil way
his dad knows his dad knows and
obviously like L knows so if elbows tab
will bring it to the cops his dad would
back him up that went so yeah yeah he's
also evil he's good yeah but his dad is
like fine with it he was like
asking him who are you right now are you
Kira or are you my son like an obvious
end of the day all they need to do is
pass the death note onto some of the new
random person and I say it's done in the
original anime manga so Ichiro the
father is much more like kind of I guess
honorbound and much more likely to be
against Kira and against light if he is
Kira in the movie the father was much
more defensive of light much a lot much
less likely to suspect light to be he
was only family to defend him and like
goals that actually like this bar like
he attacked L and slowly that because
goals I was like well I feel like this
is more realistic a father being
protective of his son and also means can
beat up random people like I think your
son's Kira oh yeah I'm gonna break your
face yes but he also he also his wife
was killed by that guy rights and now
white with the power of the Death Note
was able to correct that crime so I
could see this father in this universe
being more sympathetic to element it's
not a bad thing it's a different person
no yeah I'm not saying it's a bad thing
I'm just saying I'm just commenting that
that could be the way they go in the
sequel where yeah he knows but doesn't
necessarily expose white yeah I'm glad I
don't mind a different cast
I would have preferred it if they would
have given them different names like Mia
and light Turner if they would have
named him totally different people and
they would have had a slightly little
different dynamic
you have the same Ryo cube the same
notebook you have a different cast and
that's it and as far as the anime when
they wanted to make light look smart
they made him actually outsmart people
without mind control mind control
doesn't shout smart you are you have a
book you can tell control someone for 2
days until they die try to lose a fight
right yeah like yeah everything was just
like I'm just gonna control in he can
control people he can get info out of
them I keep it with what Betty you just
say calls them I don't know this
information I'll go find that out thanks
yeah cool
and yeah like Cole Cole mentioned this
why why didn't tell watery to kill kill
el and then commit suicide water he is
supposed to be a an alias again so that
is such a plot hole for me that he just
found out his name no 100% he water he
was the reason the original reason for
watching it was it was w he was the W of
coming out of that orphanage whatever
that's not the point so assuming that he
found out his real name because it's on
Google like most things any found water
his name and he controlled watery to
find out secret information that was in
driving distance and all that why didn't
he tell watery okay Walter you have two
days shoot light in the face and then
shoot yourself in the face why couldn't
do that yeah but he didn't want what
honey today that's the thing he wanted
okay so he could have said shoot light
and then he could have burnt the page
shoot out the point his point Oh stick
if what thought he can kill himself
people would kill him he didn't want him
to die that's why he wanted hell and he
had mind control power of everyone that
knew L so if control anyone let alone if
what I killed L and then what he just
lives what do you think will happen to
what sunny for killing L know I think I
think here that much about watering he
wanted L dead I think I see what you're
doing what you want no nuts as a point
give me a sec guys just people that are
saying that Matsuda was needed and yeah
like we maybe we needed like a more of a
comic relief character tomb in the film
but because it felt like they were just
trying hard and taking themselves too
seriously
but again that he probably have been a
longer film however I think I get what
you're saying nuts because a whites
whole focus was to get ELLs real name so
that he can kill him but you're saying
he could have just gone what are you to
shoot L in the face yeah or he could
have gotten his father to do it or
someone else in the police department
you present and then he could have burnt
the page
l was there he was in front of hundreds
of people giving a speech he couldn't
find out one guy in the town's name to
go kill L go drive your car into the
podium
you know really nuts you're missing the
point
it really lights didn't want what had he
dead
do you understand no you're missing a
factory we gone
you missing the point you're missing me
he's saying that for example he could
use water II made what we shoot L and
then once that's happened he could then
burn the page like he could give it a
set time in it so what do we shoot L
8:00 p.m. and then a day later and then
yeah and then a day later he dies once
the news is then broken out are L is
that that's it boom burn the page thunk
yeah but wouldn't people then
investigate and find out what that he's
the killer
yeah but he wouldn't okay so why
couldn't have been white find any random
bozo in the city and tell him kill L
when he's giving his speech in front of
boundary that is a good point right
there that's not a better point you're
miss like care about wanted e yeah at
the end the day even L week on week on
even if even if like I kill Elia and
then they want to investigate watery
there is no evidence for them to linked
watery to like there's none he's on the
influence of this mystical power then
you know he never even needed to meet
him face to face or talk to him so
there's no connection all he'd be like
his I don't know what happened I just
suddenly come under the urge to shoot
him and that's it oh my god further than
that Mia who also had a ton of time
alone with the Death Note could have
written anything like that what are you
gonna defend about that she has
mind-control powers now I mean Mia has
no qualms ethical qualms about killing
or having more three quick killed we
know that and you like but even if
you're gonna make believe that light
does care Mia does not correct recon yes
so she could say watery kills L right
okay so another thing remember at the
end when L got arrested
yeah yes they put him on a plane to fly
him away because they thought he was a
raving lunatic because light was in a
coma and people were dying mm-hmm and
then he says wait stop the plane the
last time I heard of people arrested
they can't really do that you can just
stop a plane and leave and go break into
some dead girl's house to find the
calculus not really no yeah I said damn
it
some people are saying yo this is really
different than the anime like yeah it's
very different than yeah I mean they
changed the rules of the Death Note they
changed the characters setting but I
think that even taking that aside and
looking at the movie just as a separate
story whether in you know in that same
universe or whatever it still doesn't
work because there's so many plot holes
and so many things that were an issue to
me like I understand that in this one
light had more like morals he didn't
want to kill innocent people he wanted
to go out of his way not to which is
something that in the original Death
Note I would have liked like more as a
character like as a person if he did
this as well I would related to him more
then but that doesn't mean that I think
in the original Death nonwhite is a bad
character I just think he's a sociopath
but that's his character I can't relate
to that part ylim cuz he goes too far
but you know like I understand that this
character this light was trying to be
more relatable but again the so much
stuff went wrong with the movie what was
relatable about this light the fact that
he didn't want to kill innocent people
that makes it like he had second
thoughts that he didn't want to kill
innocent people
hey can you tell me one person will tell
me one personality trait that he had
throughout the entire movie aside from
wanting to bang Mia
okay well kosoul maka is defending this
light as more relatable so soul the
awkward giggle when there's nothing to
say we no no um we all know you're
defending the shittiest light no yeah
yeah yeah playing - I mean he had the
whole like emo personality originally I
would guess he did he did have a sense
of justice though when he came
since like you know his feelings towards
his dad and he was talking about his
mother's killer and then also again can
you please explain what you mean by
justice I will do if you don't cut me
off
thank you yeah feelings towards the
killer of his mother like the argument
we saw him have with his father and then
also him like again sticking to his guns
making a point about that website that
came up to Kara mentioning like lists of
people's names that random people deemed
worthy to kill yes so again you know
three facts right there show that he has
a strong sense of justice in it you mean
he has hints of morality not justice he
doesn't give a crap about justice he
wanted a girl he wanted his mother's
killer dead because he had a personal
problem with him if he would have killed
someone else's mother he wouldn't have
cared at all that's not justice
justice is is fairness it's a way to
find a balance of you know to be fair in
the world that's justice yeah well
personally let's not get into that
because that's that's John Rawls says
justice and fairness but then there's
many different interpretations justice I
prefer the Platonic form of the good
version of justice what say you to that
Knox Taku hmm yeah that's not like
Turner either hmm yes not about justice
it's argument you can make the argument
that you know he sees what happened to
his mother that was an injustice that
was his first thing was to correct that
but then he's like I don't want this
happening to other people because he
mentions that so I want to help other
people make sure that they don't deal
with the same time to injustice so I
think I'm already making me mad you can
say they did it well or not but not care
about that it was in just for his mother
to be killed he just cared that it was
his mother that was dead well I'm saying
that's debatable but in the end they
didn't do a good job of showing it in my
opinion anyways Philly Superman says
they can't kill another person it is a
rule in the death note so he's saying
you can't just say what there you go
kill
person but I I didn't I didn't see that
in the movie did we actually see that in
the movie saying you can't kill another
person mind control over the person for
two days
well no we saw we saw oh no we saw one
kind of like that because the way mia
kill all the cops
she had one cop to write down the names
of all the other cops in the Death Note
yes exactly Thank You Marco yeah and
also to add to that your point Knox
about the whole you know get someone to
kill someone else that's the same way
that like Yagami could have got rid of l
know because there was no rule of mind
control he was just able to control the
circumstances of death not the actual
person for two days yeah and also in the
anime he can he killed them with heart
attacks for the most part because they
would think that heart attacks are the
only way he can do it so he here was a
lot of playing around
you know decapitation steak knives
sticking into people's throats yeah
thought it was fishy that the kid got
the ladder chopping his head off that
doesn't happen light vehicle what's your
name now me no me no no the enemy yeah
alright so she figured it out she would
have figured out that it was the ladder
that's pretty much what she did in the
anime and he killed her what about the
what about the chase scene with light
and L that was so western oh my god I
knew there was gonna be a chase here I
knew it I was like what it was hot it
was like one of those 80s Dirty Harry
scenes like runnin well your name like
you know just mine over the comm on it
here's what I did
send in that scene after L caught two
lights those like this this random guy
just came out the door and I was like
this is here right there I'm here to
investigate he just bashes L the head
thank you we needed that said for a
second and then he was like are you Kira
and it was like yeah and he just runs
off I was like what I didn't understand
that bit at all I was like yeah at the
time is going on he went through this
decision yeah Oh Joe there's that for
him lights motivation was not just as it
was vengeance teen angst and lust which
is true and then when so that you know
white did not necessarily like the
director could not make this interesting
to us like okay that's his motivation
but he didn't make him miss interesting
for us and I would agree like it wasn't
like a lot of layers in the enemy were
missed in the movie I like to stuff you
guys do not believe the different
methods of killing it was all glossed
over which makes it worse and then also
it's like yeah I don't really feel that
other than you know doubting himself and
all this other stuff that why had I
didn't feel related to him you know
necessarily I had a zero aside from
wanting to Bonilla and Nia was the worst
thing ever written what she did play a
significant role okay she played a role
yeah and she made you know look normal
you see what basically was like your
classic Kirsten Stewart character don't
get the reference here's the Stewart
like she's the one that they like the
Bella in Twilight and all those other
movies
yeah well as far as a character though
she really was pretty horrible though ya
know but she was okay she was actors she
helped she helped the pot basically
[Music]
well I don't know you mean it was all
like just teen angst it's like oh the
adult world doesn't care about us let's
get our revenge to the death
she's like the worst version of yuno
gasai it's not [ __ ] crazy Angelina
Jolie in hackus that's what she was like
no is asking you so main yeah
personality traits of Mia psycho I got
you on one soul you do too psycho
younger personality traits traits don't
think he is no no I don't think don't
say she wasn't really interested in the
light in the first place not at all she
was in him because yeah she was
power-hungry and yes she was only one of
the death no that's why she was after
him yeah I guess I mean she she felt
like it gave no reason
well you needed her to progress the plot
because there was no reason for light
who has no he doesn't give a damn about
justice to actually use it though
something needs to happen right oh yeah
[Laughter]
yeah no yeah for for Mia I don't know I
don't think she had many character like
I saw an article on Twitter this has
nothing to do with Neph death note by
the way that a feminist lady broke her
son's leg to make him equal to her
daughter
hold up sit like a scam I hope that's
like one of those you know probably in
America don't it probably one self
Senate that's why she was you look that
I did I looked up negative personality
traits
yeah but self-centered mom agreed
they're very related yeah yeah
I think everyone's self-centered and
just very not how self-centered yeah so
pick pick a character trait that not
everyone else has yeah by me like by
default I mean if you say like oh yeah
every character needs three character
traits to be a good character and we
could say would L what workout to train
to do justice which is why he didn't
want to kill people
okay sense of justice I would count that
intelligence quirkiness quirkiness yes
a weird you know social outcasts
type of character then you can be like
oh this guy's interesting he's the type
of guy he doesn't give a crap about
anything he's you know focused on his
dole and he doesn't really care what's
gonna happen he's tricky asks watery to
sing to him I mean that's not your
average I love wits those with no one's
watching you watch things I fought like
he was joking and then what do we just
went sure and just broke out into song
and I was like wait weirdest moment of
the movie not that it was bad
necessarily it was one of the better
moments that was it was weird that was
the cringe what did you guys do remember
one was singing it was a pretty crap
he's not a lazy Kuhn says PewDiePie
would have made a better eugene light i
don't know who eugene is but yeah
pewdiepie would have been a better mike
turner that's for sure what's that
what's a Bros Beauty bag
no no
and mio would come and say all right
it's time to kill everyone and say we
can't kill everyone we can't kill the
lemons we must respect the lemons right
squad tiempo de Barras that would that
would change the entire death no ass and
turn it into like some parody with
PewDiePie death no parody yes
Kaster says I would have been a better
like yes I can do emo hair I can like
put my hair down it should be like
really emo and stuff like no one
understands me there's a fine line
between yo and blazing [ __ ] that you
somehow missed what did you guys think
about the moment when light started to
scream in the classroom because they see
everyone making fun of light about that
but honestly if a nine-foot tall
big monster looking creature starts
causing whirlwinds in a classroom and
locking you in I would be crying like a
[ __ ] yeah I mean it's a normal reaction
in it I mean with reaction is like
Yagami is like a totally straight face
and then just runs away yeah it was good
it was a good thing I mean it's it's
realistic yeah I mean who the hell is
gonna look at something like that and
just go yeah okay yeah sure yeah I'm
screaming I think that's a minor thing
to improve like the plot it's like the
plot holes is what it's like that had
nothing to do with the original anime I
would have been fine a good movie
nothing to do with light or Misa or
anything doubt have been great yeah they
should just not even had the mains light
imelda it but because they did even
though it doesn't make sense to have a
guy named light in North America that
itself proves that they were trying to
make an analogy so they're inviting
comparisons yeah but I mean that was my
point before
when we first spoke about like the
adaptation getting done if it's changing
setting then everything should change to
fit that setting yeah I mean and then
that would have made it a lot a lot more
better so I totally agree with either
honestly if they would have made whoever
got the death note to be a more normal
person that didn't have a you know
didn't have on the side and he was
willing to kill people he didn't like he
was not a moral person he did not have a
sense of justice and he was willing to
kill people he did not like or did
something to him and that ended up
getting him in a situation where they
needed to find him I would have been way
more okay with that then like who's a
passive-aggressive [ __ ] with Mia
saying look yeah you want the puss
someone says for never world should have
been Rick I can't see the similar all
right guys
I mean I mean let's so water are so I
can't save a double for anime would be
the perfect light let's go into final
verdict and guys in the chat if you want
to do like a sentence or two of your
final Riddick on the movie you can do
that as well but we'll do our own that
kind of like final verdicts here on the
panel and I'll go with soul first okay
well I'll say that um overall I did like
it I know it has its flaws but every
movie does but I did look at it separate
to the world that we were the new so
yeah I was able to like it I'll give it
what a six out of ten all right okay
okay okay are we doing recon first so it
doesn't do the inhaling thing so um even
though the film did not follow the anime
adaptation at all and it was a Netflix
original I still found it I still find
Angela I would keep it a sin out of ten
to this movie there were flaws just like
soul said but it did manage to
me until the very end to watch it all
and say it was good but D satisfying
ending that killed the cliffhanger and
it's gonna be part no I'm just wondering
how was the sequel gonna go now the real
problem is that light didn't have a
harem how was the sequel gonna go it's
like death mare will cease we girls that
want light it's like they're about to do
Death Note season two when there is no
death no season two anime so yeah I
don't know no I mean if you look at the
Japanese versions they've gone to movies
to cover the original like story they've
done a third movie that just covered L
and a certain case that he did which is
actually separate yeah true mainly I
read the book yeah yeah um to you soul
unto you NOx okay so honestly I would
give it a five out of ten and all five
points are because it did not slow down
in the show in the movie it there were
no parts that really nothing was
happening but aside from that plot holes
galore and character flaws abundant yeah
I personally would give it like I would
agree with original ink in the chat I
would give it a four point five out of
ten tops like I said I enjoyed the music
but everything else even taken as its
own movie it's just like there's too
many potholes maybe if I didn't know
anything about death known previously I
would have overlooked those potholes
because I don't know what's going on but
then again it's like did you not know
what's going on because everything that
you if you didn't watch the original
anime you would be lost like crazy you
would have no idea what was happening
yeah that's what I think watch the enemy
first and then watch the movie no just
watch the anime skip the movie
the movie just watch it for just see if
you like it
I'm hoping that people watch the video i
watch the movie are gonna be never heard
of anime or death nor whatever are you
like this seems kind of interesting I'll
check out the anime and then realize all
should the animes way better and then
actually get into anime that way that
will be good yeah that way I'd say watch
first watch the other way well depends
who you're talking to I guess yeah I
mean if you ain't seen the winner then
I'd say yeah watch the movie first and
then wants the animal that's a good way
to that way your judge I mean cuz you're
not gonna the same position at one point
or another but my dad would make
terrible fun of me for watching cartoons
you know you know what I'm talking about
Dada maka
yeah no no but my parents did them have
been like that my dad gave me like tons
and tons of comics to read you know
watching the way he would know what
money
I don't wanna see stuff you know the
cartoons animated series then you would
see me watching anime and he would be
like oh look it's Buzz Lightyear I
remember once we were about to watch a
movie we were on Netflix and we're
looking through what to find something
to watch and didn't really find anything
good and you know at that point they
think they had the Dragonball Evolution
movie on Netflix oh thank you I did it
like the plague thank you but I said
okay fine I know you don't want to watch
cartoons but one episode of a show and
he said okay and I showed him the first
episode of attack on Titan because it
ends very nicely and from that moment on
he did not make fun of my cartoons
[Applause]
because showing a really dramatic an
anime episode that can get you like holy
crap this is nothing like Dora the
Explorer yeah and I think the first two
episodes of Death Note are amazing the
first two episodes like that cliffhanger
at the end where L makes his entrance at
the end of the second episode okay watch
those two episodes and you don't know
what
the show there's something wrong with
you not the show that's my Dora the
Explorer is the best anime yeah so um no
but I showed I said a tank on Titan
because the first episode ends really
well as far as first episodes attack on
Titan is a closed picture whereas Death
Note you need to and I knew I was not
going to convince him to watch - yeah
you do need the two but the two together
are really good and it is only like 40
minutes together right um I liked caster
for life's rating he gave it a double
for anime out of 10 and double for item
he made a video saying he liked the
movie no I don't know if he's his
classic trolling video or if you
actually like the movie but he did so
yeah if you guys like the movie you are
on double for enemy's side I hope you're
happy
oh wow I've yet to hear a worse you know
insult coming from you knocks what do
you make a video review in the death no
film and making your sarcastic jokes
that's a good video well no see I only
do sarcastic videos on generally decent
anime where I could point out flaws in a
sarcastic way I don't need to be
sarcastic there's no one that'll be
defending it in the comments
I'm not worried but I do have something
work yeah I know it could be funny to
make a joke out of this movie but it's
already a joke that's right so that's
the problem I told you what I was
planning on doing with it and I really
am seriously considering it now that
I've watched it yeah you told me you
were considering but you didn't well
that's because I told you I was
considering before armed it you are you
gonna do it yes yeah well it depends if
I can write the whole script still today
keep us posted guys and of course be
sure to check out NOx tacos channel link
in the description anime recon as well
his channel is in the description
soul maka is working on setting up his
channel so once we he gets that set up
we'll definitely link to his channel as
well great dude soul maka always helping
the cause all over their own discordant
if you want to join our disk or you can
do that as well link in the description
and yeah guys thank you so much for
being part of this crazy rant on donald
netflix
like i said not a big fan but we had
some diverse opinions here which is good
and also drop a like if you like Ram
cafes and feel free to suggest future
topics in the comments once the video is
posted does anyone want to say anything
else before we wrap it up guys I love
you all Thank You Rico perfect that
recons was too good I don't want to best
it I love you all I guess is our you
know final verdict oh yeah thanks guys
and until next time we're back again
next week Thursday 5:00 I'm gonna mute
you guys next time